how' you feel out there tonight I know
you had a lot of extra motivation
against your former team mhm I felt good
um felt like I right back at home uh you
know the emotions and everything was
there um it was appropriate for us to
come back and win walk us through the U
emotional when the tribute with up with
the video went up I saw you looking at a
little bit you had to turn your head on
so the teer didn't come down um it was
great um it meant a lot to me um just
seeing all the evolutions of myself
um and uh you know being a rookie doing
you know different things in the
community um growing as a basketball
player you can see the different
fashions that I started you know doing
and turning into the you know the
villain um you know it was great and you
know the warm welcoming you know the
fans were being great and um you know it
was it just felt it felt right what were
the emotions you were feeling um you
know you know a little bit of sadness
cuz you know uh I love being here um but
you know just ultimately just I guess
like you can say tears of joy um you
know just uh somewhere I can always come
back and you know feel accepted to close
it the way you did making you know
several Big Time winning plays I mean
the three in particular I mean was that
kind of the perfect ending for you here
yeah but you know I I don't want to lose
to Memphis ever in my career so you know
that's regardless of how we get it if I
go get 20 or if I have zero points you
know I want to win every single time we
play Memphis just to let them know that
you know they made a little
mistake